[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute zeige ich euch wie man richtig
leckere und knusprige süßkartoffel
pommes hinbekommen die sind wirklich
ganz ganz einfach in der herstellung und
ich nehme jetzt dafür hier die
süßkartoffeln ich rechne jetzt einfach
mal pro person eine aber ihr müsst
einfach selber wissen wie viele er ist
und die hier auch recht unterschiedlich
groß ich habe jetzt bereits gewaschen
und ich verwende die schale immer mit
ich schneide hier nur gerne diese harten
stellen weg und jetzt schneidet ihr
sehen in die größe die ihr gerne haben
möchte
ich mache immer gern so die sind
wirklich hart ich schneide dann erst mal
unten im deckel weg legte flach hin und
dann kann ich weiter schneiden
[Musik]
ich habe die süßkartoffel ein bisschen
breiter geschnitten sind einfach etwas
besondere pommes und die kleineren
stücke habe ich jetzt separat die werden
dann auch separat frittiert weil sie
eine kürzere garzeit haben
jetzt kommt das besondere und zwar
kommen die in ein stärke bat das heißt
ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen wasser das
kommt hier rein dann speisestärke und
durch die stärke die ebenso extrem
knusprig ich habe es auch schon probiert
mit trockener stärke also die anderen
stärke gewälzt aber das sehen wir nach
dem krieg ihren einfach nicht so hübsch
aus und so werden sie auch echt ein
bisschen schöner hier noch ein bisschen
paprikapulver rein für die tolle farbe
und für den geschmack was ich drauf habe
noch keinen fall nehmen und jetzt die
staaten kürzeren es geht immer ein
bisschen schwierig erst mal mit der
stärke aber dann doch gleich
und jetzt kann man dieses kartoffeln
pommes hier rein und dürfen dann darin
ein paar minuten warten wie bei samira
und eller da ist die badewanne dann zu
klein und alles schmeckt überall
während die süßkartoffel form ist noch
baden bereite ich schon mal meinen
lieblings tipp 22 uhr kam um die kurve
mole können sie auf verschiedene arten
zubereiten
da kommt es wirklich ganz darauf an wie
ihr sie ab schmeckt also ich nehme dafür
vier kleine reife avocados oder einfach
zwei große ich nehme immer gerne
zitronensaft dazu und auch viel
zitronensaft also wahrscheinlich auch
den saft von einer ganzen zitrone eine
knoblauchzehe wenn ihr keine freunde
habe danach frei eine chilischote wenn
ihr möchtet und mutig seit salz pfeffer
und etwas olivenöl und jetzt können wir
das ganze so machen dass die kommune
etwas stickig ist also mit einer gabel
zerdrücken oder fein pürieren und ich
spüre jetzt rein also dafür die avocado
einfach halbieren und ihr merkt übrigens
daran dass sie reif ist wenn sie ein
bisschen weiter ist und hier oben cages
leider keinen stingl da mal dran aber
normalerweise wenn ich im supermarkt
wird einfach hier oben diesen tipps und
wenn die avocado hier oben hellgrüne ist
dann ist er reif und die kleidung habe
ich immer ganz gerne zu hause weil ich
die zum frühstück ist und wird nicht die
einzige zu hause die avocado ist dann
wenn stein raus und dann ein frevel
auskratzen
und ich will sie jetzt ganz fein püriert
also kommt die bei mir internet surfen
die erste avocado dich probiert habe das
war damals beim steffen henssler beim
zdf
und ja die war nicht ganz nicht ganz
frei und deswegen hat er auch nicht so
gut geschmeckt er sich und dann habe ich
gelernt auch hilfreich sein
die avocado wird fein püriert und da
gebe ich gleich den zitronensaft mit
dazu und die chilischote und die
knoblauchzehe werde ich fein würfeln und
so dazu geben
[Musik]
und an der stelle können sie auch gerne
das olivenöl mit rein geben
es gibt auch varianten mit joghurt zum
beispiel das schmeckt auch sehr gut oder
auch mit tomaten
also da könnt ihr wirklich rein geben
was euch schmeckt
[Musik]
jetzt wird sich die kommune mit etwas
salz und pfeffer und kann die
knoblauchzehe dazugeben und die
chilischoten die streiche später mal
drüber
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die süßkartoffel pommes
abgegossen und sie einfach ein bisschen
abtropfen lassen und ich wäre das ganze
jetzt in der friteuse zu bereiten ihr
könnt aber auch natürlich im topf
frittieren
das fett auf etwa 180 grad erhitzen und
dann aufpassen dass sie nicht zu nass
sind also schon eine weile abtropfen
lassen und natürlich keine zu große
menge ins frittierfett geben und je nach
größe brauchen sie dann etwa zehn bis
vierzehn minuten bis eben schon
goldbraun wenig wollte von orange gold
und knusprig sind
[Musik]
jetzt sind die süßkartoffel com es
fertig und wir werden jetzt nur mit salz
und pfeffer gewürzt
so fiel auch auf dass ich gar nicht so
viel
so ich habe viel abgabe lassen ganz
frisch schmecken sie natürlich am besten
vier der kamera
diese jetzt schon kalt weil ich so vor
dass wir dran und du kriegst die frisch
also auch die mole kenny das schon
glaubt ja manchmal mache ich sie auch
mit tomate das merkt auch lecker auf
probleme und ich habe jetzt noch das
zeige ich euch noch wow ich habe hier
nämlich nur die restliche stärke
mischung siegelringe rein und hab ich ja
auch mal probieren und sagen ganz
kreativ wenn ihr was kriegt ihr tut was
machen wir eigentlich immer keine
tiefgekühlten traum ist und getöse
einmal welches zieht sofort mit dem
backen und bettelt um sich voll mit
verfallen wenn er zwei kilometer rein
was genau und wissen eine
schutzbehauptung packen ihn in die
politik juden promis werden ist aber
falsch mache das nicht das heißt am
besten frische barcelona frischen
schmeckt nichts bekannt und hier kommt
noch dass wir bringen die sind halt
holen deshalb echte cd ringen nicht wie
bei körper klingen diese zwiebel masse
da machst und schmeckt gut
sehr cool falls ihr das rezept nach
machen wollte jobs ja ist schon ein
rezept braucht kann man schon sagen dann
schaut nochmal auf meinem blog vorbei
wichtig ist wirklich dieses stärke bad
vorher die coca cola ist natürlich mein
absoluter favorit was süßkartoffel
betrifft und wenn jetzt nach macht dann
folgt uns gerne ein foto auf facebook
oder instagram ich wünsche euch viel
spaß beim nachmachen das fette entsorge
ich übrigens später ich habe jetzt zwar
frittierfett und kann es mehrmals
benutzen
jetzt habe ich aber zwiebeln schon drin
gemacht und ich habe auch schon das
zweite mal benutzt und dann nach sich es
komplett abkühlen für uns wieder in die
flasche zurück und dann könnte das zum
beispiel in den normalen restmüll
schmeißen oder ihr könnt
stelle abgeben die sich von ort zu ort
und von ort zu ort aber im mülleimer wie
gesagt können das auch reinschmeißen und
auf jeden fall drauf hat dieses komplett
abgekühlt ja und ich habe niemals
niemals in den 8
also viel spaß zum nachmachen und beim
entsorgen eures frittierfett und bis zum
nächsten mal zählen chillig ordentlich
multicore kam ohne eine nummer die
zwiebel haben chili le grau
[Musik]